this
isn't a batman movie at least not like
the ones we've become accustomed to
seeing but in a way the batman actually
fixed the superhero genre as a whole and
entirely changed the way that many
people feel about dc movies instead of
the typical hollywood blockbuster batman
formula that we've seen time and time
again we got a highly subjective and
creative hero film focused on the
character of bruce wayne which is
exactly what we needed
[Music]
before we get started here's a spoiler
warning for the batman we will be
talking about lots of spoilers in the
film so please wait to watch this video
until after you've seen it if you don't
want it to be spoiled now that that's
out of the way you might be wondering
how exactly is the batman not a batman
movie and to answer that we'll have to
discuss a few things about the film it's
sound design it's cinematography
romanticism and character also we're
going to talk about how the movie kind
of fixed the superhero genre and gave us
a new take on where the genre should be
headed first things first though we have
to talk about the film's sound this
movie was brought to life not just by
visuals but by its sound design and
mixing the soundtrack and sound design
was used to perfection and this
shouldn't come as a shock because the
film's director matt reeves is well
known for his intense focus on the sound
design for his films such as the planet
of the apes movies as well as the
cloverfield franchise both of which have
unique and utterly striking sound
production the film's composer michael g
aquino is also well known for his work
on pixar movies like ratatouille and
coco as well as big budget action films
such as star wars rogue one and avengers
end game and i think most people can
agree that ratatouille coco and end game
have some of the best musical
compositions out of any of their similar
films so gia kino's spectacular work on
the batman comes as no surprise two
specific pieces about the film's sound
design which truly set it apart from the
batman films we've been inundated with
over the past few decades are its
soundtrack and the batmobile in recent
years dc has been known for taking pop
songs and just plugging them into scenes
where they really aren't necessary see
2016's suicide squad for reference the
batman though actually treats its
soundtrack with care giving us songs
which fit the tone of the movie
perfectly and which actually makes sense
for the scenes in which they play the
song ave maria for example is played
over certain scenes with the riddler and
the tone of the song truly showcases the
insanity of his character while still
making sense for him as it would have
been a song he sing as a choir boy in
the wayne orphanage the second piece of
the film sound design which has helped
to show where superhero sound design
should be going in the future is the
batmobile this incarnation of the
batmobile is easily the least flashy of
all the batmobiles we've ever seen and
it was meant to be that way it's not a
tank or a futuristic machine it's a
handcrafted super powerful muscle car
and it certainly sounds like one there's
actually a prequel novel to the film
called before the batman which explains
how bruce began building this
incarnation of the batmobile when he was
just 16 constantly trying to find new
ways to make it faster the sound and
production designers of the film did a
fantastic job bringing this idea to life
with a striking build and an even more
striking engine sound the production and
sound designers on the film were given
lots of creative freedom when making the
batman and it really shows in the
finished product which is all the more
evident in the film's cinematography
this movie is probably one of my
favorite pieces of cinematography since
2015's the revenant the film's head
cinematographer greg frazier has always
produced stunning work most notably in
the mandalorian rogue one and dune
frazier was given a ton of creative
freedom to make the film unique and
different from all the cgi-infused
superhero films which typically dominate
the box office there are plenty of
unique shots present in the movie which
lesser cinematographers would have shied
away from but frazier went at them
straight on to give us a picture of what
personal superhero stories should look
like brutal traumatic and in the
batman's case grungy there are two shots
which i think exemplify the film's
superior cinematography with the first
being after bruce flips the penguin's
car rather than giving us a third person
omniscient view of the events unfolding
we see the menacing figure of the batman
walking towards us from the penguins
perspective giving us a feeling of being
trapped and utterly terrified the other
shot is when the batman is fighting some
goons in a pitch-black hallway lit only
by the flashes of gunfire this scene is
reminiscent of the hallway scene in
rogue one in which darth vader cuts down
an entire squadron of rebel soldiers
scenes like this just show how the
creators weren't concerned with how much
money the film was going to make but
instead focused on how they could tell a
compelling story in the most creative
way possible most of all though the
batman lets us see the world through
bruce's eyes sometimes even literally
with the help of his contact lens
cameras seeing things from bruce's
perspective differs heavily from the way
most batman movies have told their
stories in the past rather than a fourth
wall view of the happenings on screen we
get to see inside the mind of bruce
wayne just like we saw in the comics
which brings us to our next point
romanticism the batman seems like a love
letter to the best batman stories not to
the films that came before but to the
comic stories which kicked off the
intense batman fanbase the film somewhat
romanticized some of the darker and more
iconic batman comics such as hush and
the long halloween in doing so they were
able to make one of the best stories
since christopher nolan's the dark
knight or the animated dark knight
returns the film reaffirms the love and
nostalgia for batman without taking it
in the exact same direction we've seen
over and over rather than following in
the footsteps of ben affleck's batman
robert pattinson's takes on a gritty and
grungy approach that isn't cringy for
once it's realism at its height it's the
most believable of all the batman we've
seen and it doesn't waste any time with
the batman origin story that we've seen
so many times now that almost everyone
can tell exactly when the pearl necklace
will be ripped romanticism is a
subjective art form and the batman did a
spectacular job of bringing the
subjective hero story from comic book
pages and placing it directly onto the
silver screen none of this would have
been possible though without character
going into this movie i was expecting
yet another unoriginal batman story with
a twist cedric diggory is a bat but
instead of a watered-down boring take on
the same batman we've seen over and over
we got a dark and gritty story focused
on the character behind the mask bruce
wayne this film stuck to its main
objective in the story unlike the dark
knight rises which tried to accomplish
too much in too little time
similar to the dark knight rises gotham
city is seen as a character of its own
too but it's done much better this time
we actually get to see the people in the
heart of the city as they go through
traumatic events and how they recover
rather than just giving us a third
person omniscient view of the events
happening around them the film actually
gives a surprisingly compelling social
commentary about the division of
economic classes and how the ritually
often only care about themselves the
riddler and his gang of followers coined
the phrase no more lies which is just as
much of a commentary on the
socio-economic environment of the film
as it is a critique of the superhero
genre as a whole the creators of the
film recognize that audiences have
become somewhat frustrated with the
current limits of the superhero genre
and the continual stream of carbon copy
superhero films which are released so
instead of rehashing the same batman
story we've seen time and time again we
got no more lies we got a hardcore
vigilante whose brutality complicates
the heroics we usually associate with
him we got a traumatized and angry
orphan just trying to make the city a
better place most of all though we got
the world's greatest detective the same
bat that originated in ink on paper so
i'll say it again this isn't a batman
movie it's a bruce wayne movie or a
detective movie or better yet it's a
very welcome and realistic approach to
the batman character unlike any batman
movie we've ever seen before
anyways that's going to be all for today
if you liked what you saw maybe check
out the video on your screen for some
different content i make videos on
basically anything that interests me in
the world of entertainment also don't
forget to like and subscribe as it truly
does help me out and thanks for watching
rocket riley
you